now 11 years ago Paul blomfield who is
the labor MP for Sheffield Central was
in Parliament when he got a phone call
and he was told in that call that his
father had died now his dad was 87 he
had terminal lung cancer but he'd taken
his own life and since then Paul's been
campaigning for a change in the law to
allow a sister dying helping someone to
take their own life is currently illegal
and punishable with up to 14 years in
jail that's under the suicide Act of
1961. a new polling by dignity and dying
which campaigns for a change in the law
does show there is support for
Parliament to debate the issue before we
hear from Paul there is a warning that
his interview discusses suicide some
viewers may find it upsetting I
certainly did when I spoke to him
what is the current law when it comes to
assisted dying
well essentially it's illegal the
current law
prevents people having choice at the end
of their life
and it drives people to take very
desperate measures in many cases like my
father did
and also those around them if it's seen
that anyone's assisted someone in taking
it yes even
discussing their plans would make family
members complicit and of course some
people have been prosecuted for that
and what do you want to happen
I want to see a change in the law which
gives people choice
which means that for people who have a
terminal diagnosis
of six months or less and know the end
is certain
that they can choose the point
which they pass instead of in many cases
having to live out a fairly miserable
death
now you mentioned your father and of
course earlier you gave a very moving
speech in House of Commons about him and
about how he chose to take his own life
I think it was exactly eight years after
you received a phone call in Westminster
to say that he had died that you gave
this speech he was 87. what was your
father called
Harry Harry he sounds like a really
extraordinary person from what you were
saying you know you talked about him
having quite a tough upbringing in in
the East End of London yeah he was he
was brought up in poverty
the war changed it for him
um because he became an RF pilot
and uh that opened up opportunities I
mean he was offered a job as an airline
pilot but he turned it down because he
thought there was no future in
commercial Aviation
hello but um he built a very successful
business career
and he had a good life and he enjoyed it
yeah you said I think in the speech that
he was someone who made the most of his
life absolutely what kind of person was
he well he was a great father he's a
very private person but
even so I think he would
want me to talk about
his death because I know he always
believed in giving people choice and in
a sense that should have given me an
indication
of what he might do after he had a
terminal diagnosis but
I didn't really Factor him
but what kind of things did he say to
them
well he was quite positive
um even after after his diagnosis and
was trying to make the most of things
[Music]
um
and so it was a real shock
to get a call out to the blue
to say been found dead in his garage
you you said that he had a terminal
diagnosis
and it was inoperable lung cancer he was
yeah was that out of the blue or was it
something that was expected
um
he'd only talked to me about the
diagnosis a couple of months early he'd
spent the short spell in hospital
and I don't know how long because he was
such a private person I don't know how
long
um he'd actually been suffering he'd had
kind of respiratory issues but
um there was a time at which he was a
heavy smoker
um
so the actual diagnosis I think was a
shock for him and it was for us and you
say you know he's someone who sees Life
by the sound of it as well so so yeah it
has his share of health problems he'd
been diabetic for many years
just cope with them all
and you were in Westminster when you
found out news of his death it was a
phone call was it yeah
what were you doing at the time do you
remember
I think I was walking between meetings
yeah
um and it was a phone call from his
partner
I mean it must have been very difficult
to
it was really hard
obviously I got on training straight
back to uh straight back to Sheffield
and you said that you had spoken to him
the night before as well
yeah as it happened
um I've been down it was uh
on the Sunday evening and was walking
into Chambers Park
um
and we we had a perfectly ordinary
conversation
I'll say thank you for talking to us
about it I completely recognize how
difficult it is if there's any point you
want to take a breather or take a glass
of water and just just do that okay and
you said at the beginning of the
interview
is it because of the laws around a
sister dying people can't talk about
anything with their loved ones whether
it's yourself or whether it's people's
Partners you know is that something that
you feel strongly about I guess after
what happened with your father well
really strongly in this point I made in
more than one debate in the
Commons that a lot of the discussion
around assisted dying is focused on
what would the terrain look like if we
changed the law and I think we need to
give much more attention
to what the law already does to people
and the misery that it causes
so not changing the law is a
Act of
deep harm for many people
and if obviously I know you want to
speak for yourself but so it's
completely fine if you don't want to
answer this question
did his partner know about it either I
guess and that must have been difficult
for them as well
yeah I mean the point that I made is so
you know if the law had been different
as it is in other countries as it's soon
going to be in Scotland probably judging
by the moon there
um he could have talked to us
we had a plan together
he would probably have lived longer
I think he took the decision
to go prematurely
because he wanted to act well he still
could
and
if you've been able to talk we could
plan together
he'd have lived longer
and being able to dive with his family
around him
they're not at all thank you for showing
the story it's so important
sorry take a moment
with me a second no no not at all just
take one so take as long as you can it's
incredibly powerful and it is I think
the point that you make about how
there's a situation that we need to look
at the situation now is really important
like you know you talk a lot about the
risks and the downfalls of
if you change the law but you say like
not acting is also a decision
you you say that they're already looking
at changing the law in Scotland
um
what kind of thing is happening there
and would you like the same thing to be
happening in England as well well I mean
Scotland is following New Zealand
um
states in the in the US and others
who've recognized that giving people
choice is
a Humane and sensible thing to do
and Scotland's moving down the road and
it's a long lines that we would be
seeking in England to say that once
people have had that terminal diagnosis
so that their M was inevitable it was
just a question of
how and when
they should be given that choice
and you know sometimes people will say
well all we need is decent palliative
care
ironically I mean it was and that's
absolutely right we should improve
palliative care
but
my father took his decision
shortly after
uh ironically enough he'd met the
MacMillan nurse and she talked about
what the end might look like
and
at 87
he'd seen a lot of his friends die
and sometimes badly you know there is
this myth about palliative care that
people involved me do a fantastic job
but
it doesn't mean
going gently into the sunset
um in the way that it sometimes
portrayed with the very best palliative
care
many people have very bad deaths
and I think as my father thought they
should have Choice over whether they
wanted that
or they could go at their own time with
their own choosing
that's one of the arguments the path of
care argument another argument I guess
is that people worry that if a sister
dying becomes legal
then some people could be taken
advantage of that it's a slippery slope
that people who perhaps worry that they
might be a burden to their loved ones
could be encouraged
to do something that they may not really
want to do
I think those who oppose assisted dying
struggle to find reasons and that's
clearly one of the reasons that's put
forward I find it
in in my circumstances my experience
I find it quite offensive because
I think most people one belongs to live
longer yeah of course
the
you know my father would have lived
longer if he'd had choice
um the pressure that he felt
was to
take his life while he could well he
still had the choice well he still had
the capacity
because he'd seen friends
die badly without that opportunity to
act when they
realize they wanted to
um so I think
the argument is actually you can turn
the argument on its head
changing the law
will let people live longer
and
I don't see
families
using a change in the law to press
people
to go sooner
do you have any sense about what the
attitude is in Westminster towards the
sister dying or potential change in the
law
well westminster's behind the curve I
think things are changing
um over the 12 years I've been in
Parliament I think the balance is
Shifting there is more support but we
are still well behind the General Public
um the latest polling that I've seen has
something like 81 percent of people
supporting a change in the law to enable
assisted dying and that's almost
identical between supporters of the two
main parties
so apartment needs to go quite some way
to catch up with public opinion
personally I think it's only a question
of time
but the issue is
how many people are going to suffer
needlessly
until Palmer gets this act together and
changes the law in line with public
opinion
uh just finally at the beginning you
were talking about people who have only
have a certain amount of time left to
live do you think that is an important I
guess like control on it
yes I think that
now this is a
difficult area of law but frankly
that's what apartment's for we do
difficult law
um but I think that it's kind of
sensible
and balanced approach
to say six months
to live with the terminal diagnosis and
validate that's confirmed by uh doctors
is is a secure way of dealing with the
issue
and that's what most people support
so what would your message be to you
know the health secretary then
well I hope that um
the new health secretary will look
afresh at the issue
um
previous
debate has kind of got us to a point
where it looked as if the government
were going to open up discussion and
then it's pulled back
um I think that we just need an open
debate which gathers evidence
looks at people's experience
and enables us to find time empowerment
to look at the issue properly which
we've never done
thank you very much
a pleasure talking to you